picked out my face and it's got a scab
and I don't know if that's good or bad
to tell you because you can stop leave
me a comment about it I know it's there
but now if you didn't know maybe it's
all you're seeing making video content
is fun for your insecurities hi my name
is Grace help you do not know now you
know
welcome to the Internet's most mildly
tolerated game this is in the game last
week I made a video showing you how you
can make five youtuber of Halloween
costume using five items for each
costume and I'm going to repeat that
five on five please tolerate me deal
quickly you can guess what youtuber I'm
making a costume for and then see if you
win it we're all winners here let's just
jump right into it costume number one
for this first costume you're gonna need
some comfortable leggings some bug boots
a comfy shirt or sweatshirt blonde hair
as much technology iPhones cameras that
you can find an assister that you
constantly try to force on camera with
you Jenna and there you have it you are
I just seen Finn's costume you're gonna
need an outfit but the goddamn adorable
Brown perfect hair that's goddamn
adorable a bow that's goddamn adorable
some cookware that's goddamn adorable
and the inability to offend anyone even
when you say the word tada your gramma
pansino for this costume you're gonna
need a glamorous outfit that clearly
breathes welcome high heels that clearly
make your feet feel awesome some blond
hair pink pouty lips all damn day and a
master's degree in the art of Instagram
posing tada you are GG gorgeous disgust
me in a cool comfortable yet
approachable outfit a signature red lip
the longest amount of dark brown hair
I've ever seen in my life this is the
best I could do a t-shirt reference can
I get 20 drugs what up t-shirt reference
and two signature hand gesture that I
can never figure out exactly how to do
and today you're living
and costume number five first costume
you need some sort of older t-shirt with
maybe an animal face on it some Brown
boy hair a five o'clock shadow all
clocks of the day a dog that's totally
over you you know and an open love-hate
relationship with food I love you hate
you oh I love you again look at that
you're ashamed Wilson
whoa okay that's it for another youtuber
Halloween costume idea my I sorry I
should apologize for being goddamn human
I'm very sorry
leave a comment down below let me know
what other youtubers I should make
Halloween costumes for subscribe to this
YouTube channel I make videos Monday
Wednesday and Friday
also make sure you click that Bell
notifications so you can notify Berle
and make this sweet-ass content other
than that I don't know if you haven't
already gotten an I don't know so let's
shirt the link is in the description box
below there's only like six days left so
go get a mother no temperature just on
the Internet